And that is that we actually look at the gifts that God has given to us in our own bodies.
He said, "Each sense was a communication that I left between me and her."
In other words, that God is communicating with us all the time.
Her thought was a communication or a connection, or shall we say a wire if you're thinking of electricity,
or a ray of the sun if you're talking about that particular image.
So her thought was communication between my intelligence and hers.
We need to give that a little bit of thought ourselves,
because if we realize that God intended our thoughts to be a connection with His intelligence,
then wouldn't we ask Him more frequently to let that become a reality for us?
Because if it becomes more of a reality for us, then it means that we will grow in leaps and bounds,
because we will allow Him to actually come through our thoughts and our intelligence.
Secondly, her eye was communication between her light and mine.
All the spiritual writers have spoken about enlightenment, in other words, that God has put us on a journey
in which you are enlightened, you're able to take one step because there's light on it.
Then you can take a second one and a third one and a fourth one, and it's called a process of enlightenment.
So I want to give you a Proverbs 15.3 there.
The next thing is that her speech was a path of communication between her fiat and mine.
That's very interesting.
You mightn't have said that your speech was connected with his fiat,
but of course we are meant to pronounce our yes to God.
We are meant to pronounce our surrender to God.
Her heart was meant to be a connection between her love and mine.
How often we need to turn to the Lord and say to Him,
"I have no love for this person or this person in this situation.
Will you let your love flow through me to that one?"
And it's amazing what He does.
In Psalm He said, "Everything, breathing, motion, step, everything,
everything was communication between me and the creature.
I acted as more than a father who, having to set a Psalm up,
not only prepares for Him the house that closed the food and everything else
to make His Son happy, but gives power to His Son and says to Him,
"Yeah, we will separate it's true, but from afar you will feel my life."
Now first of all, I want to give you Psalm 103 verse 13.
He's more than a father to us.
And the description that's given here now that God is saying,
"You were going to be far away from Him."
He's talking about the fact that He would be in heaven and we would be on earth.
But you have the second meaning as well, the meaning of the Prodigal Son
that the human race was going to stray far from the father's house.
"We will separate it's true, but from afar you will feel my life."
Now that's actually in the story of the Prodigal Son
that He carried this memory of His Father's extraordinary love in His heart.
And that wasn't what enabled Him to come back.
And it's God's love for us that enables us to convert and come back to Him as well.
"You will feel my thought and I will feel yours."
Now there is something that is okay if you love God.
If you don't want God to have anything to do with your life
and you don't want to have anything to do with His,
it could very much feel like Big Brother is watching me.
Okay, so I want to give you the beginning of Psalm 139 there.
"You know my thoughts before I think them and my words before I say them."
In other words, God is within and without, as Saint Patrick put in his breastplate,
Christ's before me, Christ's behind me, above me, below me and everything.
Okay, "So you will feel my thought," Jesus said, "and I will feel yours."
"You will feel my breathing and I will feel yours."
Why? Because He is our very breath.
"You will feel my heartbeat and I will feel yours."
I mean, what is intimacy, if that's not intimacy?
"So we will be far," He said, "and we will be near."
"We will be separated and we will also be inseparable."
The inseparable is the union.
"And you will feel my life and I will feel yours."
Okay, so this is the discerning of God's presence in our daily lives continuously.
This doesn't require any liturgical celebration to take place for you to begin to, as we say,
enter the presence of God.
If we know the reality that we're actually dealing with,
we're in the presence of God all the time, we can't be anywhere else.
The divine will doesn't leave anybody.
Because if the divine will left anybody, we would simply cease to be.
There would be no evidence of our existence if He moved away from us.
We would just cease to be.
So that intimacy is there.
It's a case of entering into it consciously and letting it change your life and transform
you because the transformation has got to be from unlove to love, from darkness to light,
from sin to grace, and so on.
So Jesus continues, "You will feel my life and I will feel yours."
What terrestrial father cannot do for his son, because it's impossible for him?
Either celestial father did, and this son of mine, sorry, as this son of mine came out into the light,
that is, we were born onto the earth.
After I myself had prepared for him the residence of the world, well, that's Genesis chapter two,
where you're told that God had created the whole garden of Eden before Adam was actually created.
I placed such a tight bond between me and him.
Him is man representing the human race, that I was to feel his life within me.
And the creature was to feel mine.
Now, feel doesn't necessarily mean in your body.
We're inclined to connect the word feel in your body.
It means that we would recognize him all over the place.
We would know the spiritual writers talk about contemplation as a knowing,
that you know in the depths of your being.
You don't have to feel it in your body.
And he continues, "And this is my love in general and for everybody."
And why is that?
Because God is love, one John four, seven.
And Psalm one four five verse seventeen says that God only ever acts out of love.
You can't act any other way, because he is love.
And that's very important to state that, that the whole of creation comes out of love.
The creation of man comes out of love.
All of God's reactions after the fall of man all comes out of love.
And if we actually read the Old Testament in terms of love,
I think we would be surprised.
We're inclined to read it in terms of judgment.
Now, in this second paragraph, Jesus is saying,
"But there is another love, and it's the love of predilection."
Let's just take a very simple example.
I can say, "I love the Irish. I love the Irish people."
But if you fall in love with somebody and marry that person
and create a family through that person, that's a love of predilection.
That's actually different.
And so the love of predilection now is brought in here.
So what should I tell you, that's Louisa then, of the special love,
that's the singular spousal love that I have for you.
Each suffering that I have sent to you was one more communication between me and you,
and therefore one more adornment with which I embellished your soul.
Now, the aspect of Christianity that makes people run away
is the fact of suffering.
But we've been told by all the teachers from the very beginning,
from the early church fathers, that are Christian without the crosses and necronism.
The cross is right in the very center of the thing.
And in the writings of Louisa, the cross is there from the very beginning.
And so Jesus said, "Every suffering I sent to you was another special communication
between me and you."
Now, although he's talking about Louisa, these writings were not for her.
They're coming through her to the generations that were coming after her.
And so the Lord wants us to look at the fact that sufferings that we might have considered
a terrible, and we didn't want to know about them,
that they might have been a special communication between us and God.
Now, I won't go into the whole subject of suffering.
You can go into that yourself.
I will just say to you that anyone who has been through a time of suffering
and they have allowed God to work in them through it,
have come out at the other end much wiser, much humbler, much more loving,
much more tolerant, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
The very experience of suffering is like going through a spiritual operation
in which the on-love and the impatience and all the other stuff that needs to get out
is actually excised or operated on.
And you come out the other side much more healed and much more whole.
So he says, "Every suffering I sent to you was one more communication between me and you,
and therefore one more adornment with which I embellished your soul."
Now, in the hours of the Passion, and in some of the prayers of Louisa,
you hear her wanting the insignia of Christ, that we would actually be like him,
that we would be covered like him.
And so the Lord says that he adorns us through these sufferings.
So that's the first thing, each suffering.
The second thing is each truth that I've manifested to you
was a particle of my qualities with which I embellished and filled your soul.
Now, we who are studying the writings of Louisa can make the mistake of sort of
looking at the thing in general and sort of getting the gist of it.
I suggested that's a big mistake.
What we have to do is make sure that each truth that has been revealed,
that I've actually got it.
Know the way they say nowadays, "Got it?"
Okay, I have to make sure I've got it.
That means it's gone into my head, that it has been absorbed into my soul,
and that I am now living this so that each truth is actually a step forward.
So listen to what Jesus says, "Each truth I have manifested to you
was a particle of my qualities with which I embellished and filled your soul."
So each truth is very important for building up the new heavens and the new earth that he
wants to build inside of us.
Now, number three, each grace and number four, each coming of mine,
so he's talking about Louisa here, each visit of his to you were gifts that I poured upon you.
"I did nothing but multiply my communications almost as each instant,
so as to portray in you my various beauties my likeness."
Now, that's two Corinthians 3, 18, that we become like that which we worship.
"That you might live with me in heaven and that I might live with you on earth."
That's wonderful stuff.
Jesus is saying, "As we're growing in his likeness,
as we are letting the divine will take over more and more and more,
we are learning to live in heaven while we are on earth,
and we're allowing him to live on earth while he is in heaven."
So this is extremely important so that we are opening the path for his return.
He could only come to souls who are ready and are letting the divine will
operate in their lives.
This is a very important point.
And after all this, he said to Louisa, "You doubt about my love?"
I think he's saying that with a smile, of course, because he knows that Louisa's terrible
longings for him are due to the extraordinary love that she has for him.
That she literally can't tolerate him not being there in every sense of the word.
Rather, he says, "Think about loving me and I will think about loving you even more."
So this is a tiny little correction for the one he loves the most.
And that is, he says, "If you stopped thinking about yourself and how you felt
and how things were going on for you and you gave all your attention to me,
you'd actually go faster."
Now, for those of us who are not at Louisa's heights,
I think that piece of information is vital for our progress.
And that is that if we would stop thinking about how I am inside, how I am outside,
how things are going for me and all the rest of it, if I would just stop that
and give all that energy and all that attention to loving Jesus
and loving my neighbor through him, with him and in him,
I would take wings and fly very fast.
I want to give you a proverb, 23/7 there, "As a man thinks, so is he."
We would say in modern English, you are what you think.
So I want to go on to October the 17th, 1924.
Again, we're still talking about God's love for us.
Louisa said, "I was thinking of the great love of which Jesus has for us."
In other words, continuation of the last message.
And his great love for us, I want to give you John 15.9,
"As the Father has loved me, so in the same way, I have loved you."
And then he says, "And that's the way that you have to love one another."
Okay, so we're continuing now from the last message.
She said, "My mind wandered within the eternal love."
That means she's meditating, she's contemplating on it.
And my sweet Jesus, moving in my interior, which means, of course,
that the kingdom of heaven is there.
That's Luke 17, 21, the kingdom of God is within you.
And one Corinthians 3, 16, "No, you, not that you are the temple of the living God."
And that the Spirit of God dwells in you.
So Jesus moved in her interior and showed her spokes of light.
Now, if you think of a bicycle, you have the picture.
And the spokes are of light.
And within these spokes, there is a sun and the very center.
Okay, and this sun contained as many rays, listen to this,
for as many existing creatures, each creature had a ray all for herself.
Now, this is a new image that she's actually using.
We're used to her saying that the divine will is like the sun.
But here she's saying that each one of us is a ray coming out of that sun.
I think that's brilliant.
And this ray is all for yourself and it gives you life.
Now, if God has given a special ray from his divine sun to each one of us,
then we can confidently, absolutely turn to him and ask him to give us the fullness of it
and to enable us to be able to receive it and to use it to our benefit and for his glory.
So each creature had a ray all for herself, which gave her life, light, heat, strength and growth.
In other words, everything that was necessary to form a life.
So here you've been told that the divine will is actually the primary source of our being.
It was delightful to see how each creature was attached to the ray of this sun,
like a branch to the vine.
So there you have John 15, "I am the vine and you are my branches."
And my mind was wandering within this and he said, "My daughter, see with how much love I love the
creature." Okay? Before coming out to the light of day in this world, she was already in my womb.
This is very important because as we enter into real, committed, final, permanent union with God,
we become a birth from his womb.
Okay? And I want to give you John 3.16, "Unless a man is born again from above,
he can't even enter." Now Jesus used that message to, first of all, introduce the church
to entering in, out of the world, into the church through water and the Holy Spirit.
And now you can apply that to us on the level of entering fully and finally into the divine will
and being born again of the Spirit of God, being born from the womb of God.
So before coming out into the light of day of this world that is being born from your mother,
the soul was already in my womb and in delivering her, I did not leave her. Now this is the big issue
with between Louisa and Jesus all the time that apparently he's leaving her and he keeps on telling
her, "I haven't left you. It's actually now possible for me to leave you." Okay? He said,
"And he's talking about any soul being born into the world, not just special people like Louisa.
I did not leave her. The divine will is there in the center of our being. A ray of light containing
my life follows her in order to administer to her everything that is necessary so as to carry out
this life." Now he's talking about the divine life in us. I forget the name of the poet that said
the children are born trailing clouds of glory after them. They really remember for quite some
time where they actually came from. "And with how much care do I not raise her?" he said,
"So beside that I want to give you Sam 23. The Lord is my shepherd so I lack nothing.
If you want to change the word shepherd, the Lord is my carer. I lack nothing. Or the Lord is my
mother or the Lord is my father or the Lord is my life giver. Whatever it is, I lack nothing.
With how much love do I not water her? That is take care of the soul again." Now watch this.
"I myself..." Now here you've got the humility of God in a way that's totally, utterly amazing.
"I myself make myself into light, heat, food and defense for her."
There's God completely at the disposal of the soul. Now what I want to do is remind you there
of the book of Exodus because it was in the wilderness and the very first experience
of walking with God that human beings discovered what we call the creed. He is my father. He guides
me. He is my light. They had the pillar of fire. He's my protector. They had the pillar of cloud.
He's my food. They had the manna. He's my drink. They had the water from the rock. He's my healer.
He healed them from the snakes and so on and so forth. And so when you study the
Torah, the first five books of the Bible, what you find is that one of the fascinating things,
if you could read it in the original, in the Hebrew, is that they keep on giving titles to God.
The Lord is my this. The Lord is my that. The Lord is my the other. And it's absolutely fascinating.
And it means that God in fact, now we're not talking about special believers here,
this is for all human beings, that God is in fact totally serving us and our needs.
It's utterly amazing. So when you look at something like this and you look at human pride,
you see how terrifying the human pride actually is. I myself make myself into
light, heat, food and defense. Now when Jesus became incarnate and lived in Israel, in his public
ministry, he made himself a servant. He provided food. He provided miracles on the water. He provided
healing. He provided life. Absolutely. We were looking at what God actually does for all souls as well.
And so he continues and when she completes her days in time, when we die, along the same,
along the path of that same ray, so we come out on this ray and we go back on the same ray.
That's interesting. If I can use a modern example, you get a return ticket.
I withdraw her back into my womb. Now for that, I want to give you Revelation chapter 7,
verses 9 to 17, where you'll see the souls in great numbers gone back into the womb of God.
To let her wander through the celestial fatherland. Now notice wonder. That's a very interesting one,
because the Louisa is going to start describing. She's already started it. In fact, describing
the divine will as an immense sea or an immense void or an immense space. But whatever it is,
it's immense. And the more she goes on in these writings, the more she says, once you go into it,
you'll never find a way out of it. And so our idea that we got in childhood that you'd be sitting
on a cloud playing a harp doing nothing, getting utterly bored is not correct at all. And so this
wandering through the celestial fatherland means that there will be an absolutely eternal amount
of exploring to do and finding out and growing and all the rest of it. My love for the creature
makes itself as more than the sun which I formed in the Asia heavens. Even more, the sun I created
for the benefit of the human race. My book says human nature. It should be human race.
The sun in the heavens is nothing other than the shadow of my true sun that's himself. In fact,
the sun in the sky does not form plants nor does it give them water so as to stop them from withering.
Nor does it provide all those aids which are necessary so that the plants may grow beautiful
and strong. And men, even if they're blind, can actually appreciate the light.
The only thing the sun in the sky does is its office of illuminating and warming and it moves
on. And if the plants are not watered, the sun can do nothing to communicate its effects to them
rather it will wither them even more because it will stay giving them light and heat.
On the other hand, he said, I who am the true sun, I do not leave them. Notice that the repetition
of I do not leave you, I do not leave you. I do not leave them either at night, Sam 1, 2, 1 verse 4,
or by day. And he's now going to give us a list of seven points. Usually when the Lord makes promises
about how he operates with us, usually in sevens. Number one, I myself form souls. That's Ephesians
210, where God's work of art. Number two, I give them the water of my grace so as not to let them
wither. Number three, I nourish them with the light of my truths. Now for the water, I want to give
you Isaiah 55 1, where you're invited to come and drink as much as you like. And John 7 37 to 39,
where again Jesus says, come and drink. Now number four, I straighten them with my examples.
Number five, I give them the wind of my caresses and that absolutely divine expression. When I went
for my first walk in six weeks today, I really appreciated the wind, the wind just flowing past
the face and blowing the hair around the place. It was absolutely delightful. I give them the wind
of my caresses to purify them. Number six, I give them the Jew of my carisms to embellish them.
And number seven, I give them the arrows of my love to warn them. Now that is much better if you
just write a little note for yourself one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, and you'll realize he
cares for everything that we need. He is everything I am not. In some he said, there's nothing I don't do.
I am all for them. Now the only thing you can do with that is actually take it off the page
and write it out by itself. It's the kind of thing that I write up on the fridge. I am all for you
or I am all for them. It really strikes you when you see it all by itself. I am all for them.
And I place the whole of my life at each person's disposal. Now please take that one out of the book.
Please do that. Jesus has placed everything in his life at your disposal and mine. I can take
from his life anything I want. And if I don't do it, I'm just being silly. I often describe Catholics
as people who starve to death outside of a bank that they own. If we didn't own the bank,
the starvation would be a different subject. But here we have the whole of Jesus' life at our
disposal and we have to clothe ourselves with it and let him bring us to the height of holiness
that he wants us to go. But how much in gratitude he said on the part of creatures? They seem to
be attached like branches to my vine, not out of love but by force. Now I'm sure you've all seen
this where people sort of feel obliged to go to church or do I have to go on all this kind of stuff.
They feel obliged. There's no love there. And what the Lord wants is that we would be attached to
him by love, his divine love, and our responding love. We're going to come to that. They seem to
be attached like branches to my vine. He said not out of love but by force because they can't do
without me. They can't do without the divine will. That's the source of our lives. And so they grow
like those branches which not receiving all the good humors that the vine contains. They grow thin
without ever forming mature grapes but on ripe ones. Now Jeremiah and Ezekiel have a lot to say
about that and all I'm going to do is give you Jeremiah 31 29 where at the time that he is speaking
which is around the time when the kingdom of Judah was to be sent out into exile and then
the northern kingdom had already been sent out into exile and now the southern kingdom
was to be sent out. That meant the entire nation failed God. And Jeremiah said that you were planted
as a glorious vine and you brought forth sour grapes. I think we're at the stage where what
Jeremiah said to those people can be said again today that every denomination and Christianity
has failed God. If we haven't, why haven't we solved the problem of the world?
So Jesus said ah if all knew how I love their souls all would be captured by the strength
and by the attractiveness of my love and they would love me more. Therefore you,
Louisa, you should love me he said and may your love expand so much as to love me for everyone.
Now it's addressed first of all to Louisa and secondarily to you and me that the Lord wants us
to let our love expand, to really love him and glorify him and bless him and repair him for everybody
and to do it with more and more and more energy and gusto. So let's go to October 23, 1924.
Louisa said, I'm going through bitter days because of the privation of my sweet Jesus.
Oh how I miss his lovable presence, Sam 42. I have nothing but tears for my bread,
night and day as he say to me all day long, where is your God? Okay. Oh how I miss his lovable presence.
Even just the memory of his sweet words wounds my poor heart and I say to myself,
now where is he? Where did he directly steps? Where will I find him? Everything is over. I no
longer see him. Now for that I want to give you song of songs chapter three versus one to two.
It's the bride feeling that she has lost her spouse and goes looking for the bridegroom.
I also want to give you John chapter 20 from verse one at least to verse 10. It's probably
further where Mary of Magdalene is searching for her beloved as well. And I also want to give you
the whole chapter of 24 of Saint Luke where the two disciples on the road to Emmaus couldn't stay
in Jerusalem when of him they saw nothing. And they couldn't take stories of resurrection or
anything if they if they couldn't see Jesus life was intolerable so they decided to get out and he
joined them which is wonderful. So Louisa is having that kind of pain. She said, I no longer see him.
I no longer hear his voice. We will no longer pray together. Okay. The last time she gave us a message
was the 17th of the month and this is the 23rd so she's finding it rather difficult.
We no longer pray together how hard is my destiny? What torment? What pain? Oh Jesus how you have
changed? She said, how could you run away from me? But though far away now she gets 10 out of 10 for
this one. First of all she gives you this wonderful description of the her desperate need for him
and then all of a sudden she gets the solution. She's done this a few times and each time she does
it it's really fantastic. She said, but though you are far away on the wings of your will wherever
you are I send you my kisses my love and my cry of sorrow which tells you come come back to your
poor exiled one. That is the secret for you and me that whether you sent him near or far that on
the wings of the divine will you send him everything. That's fantastic. So she said,
when I was saying this and other things Jesus moved in my interior and extending his arms he
clasped me very tightly. So the poor girl needed a big hug and Louisa said to him my life my Jesus
I can endure no more help me give me strength do not leave me again take me with you I want to
come now I want to come to heaven. She's about the only one you probably ever met who really badly
wanted to die but for the right reasons. Some people want to die for all the wrong reasons just to
get away from pain and to commit suicide. So she said I want to come and so Jesus has got to
come around delicately to tell her that you know you have committed yourself to the divine will
and she's going to use a feminine trick on him. She says I am with the divine will lives in heaven
he said yeah but it needs an awful lot of work to do on earth and he's got a persuader
to continue her work on earth. This is actually very beautiful the way it's done.
So she said that Jesus interrupted her and said to her my doctor don't you want to do my will
you said of course I want to do your will but your will is also in heaven she said thinking that
she's won the the argument at long last. Now before we go on I want to give you two Corinthians five
verses one to ten. Of course I want to do your will she said but it's also in heaven. So if until
now I have done it on earth from now on I want to come and do it in heaven therefore hurry and
take me and do not leave me here anymore I feel I can endure no more so I have pity on me. So Jesus
to use very human language had to take a deep breath to try and get her to to accept his will.
So he said my daughter you do not know what my will on earth is. Now he's been
this is our 17th volume she should know but the point is how often have you and I read these texts
and you've forgotten all about them and you go back and read them and say my goodness was that
there when I read it the last time. You don't know what my will on earth is he said it shows how
after so many lessons you've not understood well. Now I can't see you if I asked you to put your
hand up I put my two hands up you don't understand well you must know that the soul who lets my will
live within herself as she prays as she suffers as she works my book says operate as she loves
etc she forms a sweet enchantment to the divine pupils he's talking about now operating on earth
she's wanting to operate in heaven so it forms a sweet enchantment to the divine pupils in such a
way as to enclose with her acte the gaze of God in that enchantment you can really capture
the presence of God you can capture his attention it's really fantastic and you do it in such a way
he said that I am captured by the sweetness of this enchantment it has the power of preventing
my justice from pouring itself out and all it's fury upon the face of the earth with many of the
chastisements which creatures draw upon themselves with their grave sins oh oh this means that when
we're doing our acts we're preventing the fierceness of chastisement we're toning it down for everybody
and Jesus is saying wouldn't you want to stay to do that that's why he gave you two Corinthians 5
verses 1 to 10 where St Paul said he wanted to take off the tent of this body and go to God in glory
but he realized that he had a task to do on the earth and so out of love for God he would stay
and Jesus continued he said look my justice too receives the enchantment of my will
operating in the creature do you think it's trivial that the creator sees in creatures who are still
living on the earth his own will operating triumphing dominating with the same freedom with which
operates and dominates in heaven he's saying you haven't grasped the enormity of this at all
no wonder it captures his attention and he's going to tell her it captures the attention of all
heaven as well and so in the next paragraph he's going to say to her look the saints in heaven have
finished their work they're into celebration but we've a lot of work to do on the earth
it's on the earth that we have to conquer souls and we have to try and bring them into the kingdom of
God we've a lot of work to do and it's is saying to her Luisa you can't afford to die there's too
much to do anyway Luisa doesn't know she's not even halfway through these messages
volume 18 is halfway through volume 36 she has no idea of the enormity of the work that's still
waiting for her so he continues this enchantment he said that he's talking about it's not present
in heaven because in my kingdom my will dominates as if it was in its own house naturally
and the enchantment is formed within myself not outside of me now you see he's been saying
that somebody living in the divine will and doing acts in the divine will forms this
enchantment for him on the earth that's outside of his kingdom he's conquering on the earth
but the saints in heaven it's all inside of him and he's the source of all their happiness
he's trying to say that we are the source of his happiness on the earth when we participate fully
but he said that's all inside of me he said it's not outside of me therefore it is I it is my
will that enchants the blessed with an unwrapturing strength in such a way that their pupils
are enclosed in my enchantment to the light is eternally so it's not they who form the sweet
enchantment for me is the folks on the earth but I for them and so my pupils are free and receive
no fascination on the other hand while living in the creature who is crossing the desert of the
exile on earth my will is as though working or operative and dominant in the house of the creature
now notice the house of the father is heaven the house of the creature is on earth because
Adam was made lord of the earth now it is in the house of the creature and this is why she is the
one who forms the enchantment for me she fascinates me and she makes my gaze receives such attraction
as to capture me to fix my pupils upon her without being able to remove them that means
you've actually attracted the gaze of god isn't that amazing you've caught his attention
and the lord is looking down on us poor little nothings trying to live in the divine will and
trying to open up to him and trying to do our acts as best we can and he's fascinated that
there we are trying to open the way for the kingdom of heaven firm on the earth that's his fascination
because don't forget from millennia human beings have not lived in the divine will and so of course
he'd be fascinated seeing this new layer of children trying to seek and they do what Adam did you know
before he fell so he said that's my enchantment you do not know how necessary this enchantment is
in these times how many evils will come is this is only 1924 that's a century ago
the people will be forced to eat one another now he's not talking about cannibalism that eating up
I think is world war two and possibly world war three which might be threatening now
they will be taken by such rage as to become ferocious against one another well they certainly
were ferocious in world war two but the greatest fault he said is with the leaders
now if you've studied the Old Testament you'll find that all the prophets when things went wrong
in the nation the prophets continuously laid the entire blame at the feet of the prophets priests
and kings they were the leaders they said if they were doing things right the people would have proper
leadership and they would follow and here's Jesus again saying that the greatest fault is
with the leaders so if you think of the second world war you think of Hitler and Stalin and
Paul pot and all the others there was a whole string of them poor people Jesus said they have
true sufferers incarnate devils as leaders now that's Jesus speaking and he's the truth if
that's God's discernment it's no wonder it was hell on earth and these incarnate devils as leaders
want to make a slaughter of their own brothers just think of the millions that Stalin killed
in his own nation apart from anything else if you think of the numbers that Paul pot destroyed in
his own nation just to take two examples if the events were not grave your Jesus would not leave
you as though without him he said you fear that it may be because of other things that I deprive
you of me but no be assured now he's given her this assurance for 17 volumes i don't know when
you get the point but I suppose it needs to be in her pain and in her circumstances to understand
her reactions it's my justice he said that is depriving you of me because it wants to unload itself
in chastisements upon creatures you however never go out of my will so that its sweet enchantment
may spare the people worst evils now look at what he's saying that we who are trying to live in the
divine will trying to do our acts are in fact holding back ferocious chastisements we should
begin to appreciate that so let's look at October the 30th 1924 and it's going to talk about angels
so louisa said I feel I can't entrust my sorrowful secrets to the pen nor express on paper what I
feel about my martyrdom my martyred heart now louisa is speaking there of what the ancient Irish
church called the white martyrdom the martyrdom of the heart okay and you will get details on that
in the message coming up so I'll just let it come up naturally ah yes she said there's no
martyrdom which can compare to the martyrdom of the privation of my jesus what she really means
is there's no greater martyrdom than the martyrdom of love and that's what jesus is going to explain
to her the martyrdom the martyr that is the one who is killed in the body is wounded and killed in
the body while the martyrdom of his privation wounds the soul that's the martyrdom of love
it lacerates her inner innermost fibers and what is worse it kills her without making her die
to strike her continuously on the iron anvil of pain and love now if you want to understand that
there's an advertisement on our te sometimes before the six o'clock news and it shows you a man
working with iron and exactly he actually makes an iron rose and you see that to make this metal
pliable so that he can make the rose out of it he's got to put it into very great heat and he's got
to soften it and he's got to hammer it and he's he's the hammer in the anvil it's just unbelievable
and when i look at that i i realized this is what is being said here that something incredible is
being done with luisa which she can't see because i'm sure if you asked the iron that was in the fire
it wouldn't be able to describe it either it would only be able to talk about pain
and so she says and i pass over the pains i feel in my interior now this is separate from
the deep privation that she suffers so she's actually really in desperate pain all the time
and so i pass over the pains i feel in my interior because these are things which i'm
unable to talk about and as one of the poorest beggars on the planet i would like to beg everyone
the angels the saints my queen mother the whole of creation for a word a little prayer to Jesus
for me so that prayed by all he might be moved to compassion for his the little daughter of his will
and let her come back from the heart exile in which i find myself in other words let me go home
and she asked everybody in heaven and on earth to pray that she can go home
that's after he has told her about the importance of doing all the divine will work on the earth
it's fascinating you need to know what deep pain is to understand why you go from one to the other
like that and then she said i was thinking to myself about what had passed through my mind
that is that instead of Jesus it seems to me as if i had my angel near me now i love this
if you've had Jesus himself you don't want angels so i want to give you john chapter 20
verses 11 to 13 mary of magdalene was seeking Jesus on the morning of the resurrection
and because she was seeking Jesus she was not even interested in the angels nowadays were so
poverty stricken that if somebody sees an angel they write a book about it
a mary of magdalene wanted nothing to do with the angel she just simply said where have you laid
she's looking for him uh luisa is looking for Jesus so while our guardian angel is nice and
all the rest of it where's he why can't i have him you have the same thing in in luke 24 with the
two disciples on the road to amaeus they tell jesus actually they're the only ones who ever
evangelised jesus so they tell jesus the whole story of the uh death and resurrection and when
when they're finished they say but of him they saw nothing and if they can't have jesus you can
keep your stories of resurrection you can keep anything you like the only thing we can tolerate
is to have him back and without even realising it those men were making the same confession
of love that luisa is making here so she wants to know why she's gone down
in the hierarchy and she only has an angel so jesus takes the opportunity of teaching her about
angels but i think it's lovely at that moment she said i felt himself move in my interior that's your
luke 17 21 and 1 Corinthians 3 16 and he said my daughter do you want to know why the angels are
angels i mean you're just dismissing them and do you mind i have millions of these creatures
in my kingdom can we talk about it uh would you like to know why they have kept themselves
beautiful and pure as they came out of my hands it is because they have always remained in that
primary act where we're aiming at going into that initial fiat that eternal fiat of god
they've remained there he said in which they were created therefore being in that primary
act of their existence they are in the single fiat of god or the single act of god which
not knowing a succession of acts does not change it neither decreases nor increases and contains
within itself all possible imaginable goods so we're continuously told that the divine will
contains everything that's necessary for the universe angels human beings everything
the divine will has everything so it is all possible and imaginable goods but the angels
keeping themselves in that single act of my will that's where oh yeah he's going to say it anyway
which issued them into the light they maintain themselves immutable immutable is that you don't
change you're going to remain that you're going to be completely stable at that point
and because they're completely immutable and stable in their commitment to god
they remain beautiful and pure now pure is a much bigger word than it was when i was growing up
when i was growing up pure only had to do with the sixth and ninth commandments
but you and i know that if you go to a concert listening to magnificent music and there's one or
two notes wrong you just once that impurity goes into which you can't tolerate it we all love water
but if there's an impurity in the water it's terrible impurity is a much bigger word than they
used to talk about and it means there's something mixed in that shouldn't be there and so the
impure motivations is not necessarily to do it sex or anything like that it is that i have mixed
a little bit of selfishness in with what i say is my love for god and that little bit of selfishness
is very impure to go so if they have remained pure it means that they their motivation for serving
god is absolutely pristine they have lost nothing of their original existence and all their
happiness is maintaining themselves voluntarily notice the free will because we do know that the
angels were given a test and that one third of the angels led by lucifer said i will not serve
so they had free will and you're going to hear this about the saints as well
so they maintain themselves voluntarily in the single act of my will
i think it's lovely that they're doing it voluntarily they find everything in the circuit of my will
nor do they want in order to be happy anything other than my will administers to them in other
words they know by experience that everything you need really is in the divine will but do you know
why there are different choirs of angels and this is just really interesting because he will come back
to this at a later point because there's going to be nine choirs of the children of the divine will as
well but you know why there are different choirs of angels one superior to the other there are some
who are closer to my throne now we know that about archangels and the carobim and the seraphim and so
on but you know why it's because to some my will manifested only one act of my will and it manifested
two to others and three to others and even seven to others so it depended on how much
god actually revealed of himself so i want to give you look 19 verses 11 to 27 they parable of the
talents that uh so this is given to some and that's given to others that's given to others
but unlike the angels in the parable of the talents human beings reacted negatively to god's choice
so the divine will revealed different things to the angels and in each thing pertaining to the
additional act which my will manifested some were made superior to others so it was that divine
revelation can you imagine how superior louisa is then receiving this full divine revelation
about the the kingdom of the divine will the angels must have been fascinated
so this is what made some superior to others and were rendered more capable and worthy to be
close to my throne now rendered more capable only god could do that and when you hear Jesus
in several places in the writings of louisa talking about the amaclic conception of our blessed mother
he says that he had to render her capable of conceiving the son of god as a creature she couldn't do that
and the son of man was also to be the son of god he was to be divine as well as human
that all the graces the seas of graces poured into her were to enable her to be able to do that
it is god who is the source of everything we get everything from him
the different things that were revealed to the angels god made them rendered them more capable
and worthy to be close to his throne so watch this the more my will manifests itself and they
keep themselves in it the more they are raised embellished made happy and superior to others
that is the principle for us as well to watch this the more the divine will manifest itself
and it just manifested itself fully in these writings i don't know how long it'll take us to
get through them all um the more we keep ourselves in the divine will because you have to do it
voluntarily do you remember the angels up there they did it voluntarily uh the more we keep ourselves
in the divine will after the lord has revealed something to us the more we are raised embellished
made happy and superior to well superior means you have a different relationship with god
and you've more power to make a difference upon the earth so he says see then how everything is in my
will and everything is in keeping themselves without ever going out in that same will from which they
came and from their greater or lesser knowledge of my supreme will are the different choirs of angels
constituted their distinct beauties their different offices and the celestial hierarchy so the whole
thing was arranged by god so the whole thing is perfect and the whole thing is in harmony and since
all of them keep themselves in the divine will the harmony is beyond anything we could imagine
i had a death experience when i was about nine or ten i could be wrong on the age but it was around
there and one of the things i experienced not as i said one of one of the things i experienced was
that i heard the choirs of angels singing it was so divine the harmonies were so unbelievable
that it spoiled me from listening to music forever modern music is completely hellish as far as i'm
concerned we know nothing about their harmonies it is totally amazing
and to call it sweet is it is there's no language for it i actually understand louisa
not having language for saying something she actually experienced so they have their distinct
beauties their different offices and the celestial hierarchy in the celestial hierarchy and then
jesus said if you knew what it means to know my will more you do more accident so there you are
see how terribly important it is for us to study these writings and to keep studying them
and if there's something you don't understand at this particular moment that's okay let it go
there will be something else that will speak to you and then you go back when you're ready
and you'll find that what didn't speak to you today will speak to you next year or whatever
um but the more acts we do in the divine will the more we we grow
oh he said if you only knew what it means to know my will more and to do more acts in it
to keep oneself and to act in that will of mine which one has known by which the office the beauty
the superiority of each creature is constituted oh how much more would you appreciate the different
degrees of knowledge the translation that we have it's not too bad but it keeps on using the word
knowledges which is a nonsense in english and so what jesus is talking about is that we get
different degrees of knowledge given to us when you send a child to primary school
they're going to go through an entire process uh until they're adult of getting different degrees
of knowledge different levels of knowledge and as they imbibe that knowledge into themselves
they grow and they mature jesus is talking about that in the divine will as well the different
degrees of knowledge that he gives to us um so he said you would appreciate the different degrees
of knowledge that i manifest to you about my will one more piece of knowledge about my will
raises the soul to such a sublime height that the very angels are stupefied of course they're
stupefied if he's giving us more and more and more revelation in the divine will and we are
lower creatures than they are and they've only been given one or two or three or four or seven
or whatever when you think it through it's totally mind-boggling the very angels are stupefied
and they're in rapture they can't believe it and they keep confessing me incessantly holy holy
holy is the lord god of hosts that's Isaiah chapter six verse three i also want to give you
revelation for eight so they keep on proclaiming this so i now want to give you seven more promises
that you're going to have to write out yourself uh to clarify them to make sure you really see them
number one my will manifests itself now that's going to be repeated but i've written it down
it's number one because if the divine will doesn't manifest itself nothing else happens
number two it calls things from nothing that's a statement that is infinitely more important than
you think the very first words of the bible are in the beginning god created that bada ba or a
in phonetics and bada means created out of nothing okay at the very beginning of this divine will
revelation right back in chapter one the lord encourages us to get into our nothingness why does
he want us in our nothingness is he trying to crush us and keep us small and unimportant or
blah blah blah no he creates out of nothing and when we go into our nothingness we are giving him
the space to create new heavens and new earth in us and that's why the nothingness is absolutely
essential for any movement in the divine will so the number first thing is that the divine will
manifests of the second thing is that the divine will calls things from nothing number three it forms
beings that's genesis chapter two and in genesis chapter two you have a description of a lot of
trouble going to make this atom number four the divine will manifest itself and embellishes
that's like saying now that you have the creature start giving him all kinds of gifts and genesis
two seven says it's at that point that the spirit of god was poured into man and man became a living
being that means spiritually as well so it manifests itself and it embellishes number five it manifests
itself and it raises the creature higher now that's what he wants to do all the time and as we've just
read with each truth that he manifests and that we take into ourselves and we absorb and we try to
live he's raising us higher and higher all the time number six it manifests itself and it expands
the divine life more in us that means our capacity for god increases and our capacity to receive
everything that god is giving to us increases number seven is that the divine will manifest itself
and forms in the soul new portents never before known this is terribly important god is a creator
he's not he doesn't pat remember jesus said that christianity was not a pat on judaism he doesn't
pat he creates and when you study the bible you find that every single time the human race messes up
god's plan god comes up the better one and he he uses every single challenge as a challenge to show
more about himself and to give more it's really fascinating to watch so what i want to say to you
is that if you think that you and i or any of us are going to be copies of each other
the answer is no he's going to create completely new heavens and new earth inside of each one of us
his delight is the diversity he wanted the nine choirs of angels he wanted archangels he wanted
caribou me wanted seraphim he wanted guardian angels he wanted this and that and the other
he loves diversity and he loves to see the extraordinary balance that come into
thing if you look at a beautiful painting of a very good artist you'll find that they love the
multiplicity of colors and the delicate shades going in and then you need the dark shades to show
that up and all the rest of it and it's all the shades that are needed as the same thing if you
look at a beautiful piece of music that you first of all have the the general thread that will go
through and then the author needs to put in all kinds of things and weaves other little tunes and
everything into it to make this wonderful complex thing that that's a that's a creative person at
work and the lord will do that as well so he will give graces to people that have never been seen
before and he will give gifts that have not been seen before and we just need to realize that
so i think that over every divine will dwelling shall i call it we should have a notice of danger
god at work it's wonderful so he's going to uh he's going to bring forth new portons never known
before wonderful stuff so god wants to make something beautiful out of each one of us and he will
tell us when we go a little bit further in the volumes that he wants nine choirs of the the children
of the divine will now he was the one who decided who was in the choirs of angels but the extraordinary
thing is he says that we choose which of the nine choirs we are part of by the acte we do and how
much of the divine will that we absorb no wonder he's fascinated to see us trying to make a cake
out of his ingredients that's wonderful so from the many things he said that i have manifested to you
luisa about my will you can understand what i want to make of you in other words you're getting
all of this stuff and how i love you he said and how your life must be a chain of continuous acts
done in my will and of course the more acts the higher you're raised if the creature like the angel
that's the creature knows the human being let's put it this way if we like the angel never went
out of that primary act within which my will issued her to the light what order what portents
would not be seen upon the earth if only like our blessed mother we stayed totally absolutely
within the divine will he said the earth would be flooded with miracles therefore my daughter
never go out of your origin he said in which my will created you and let your primary act
be always my will so it has to be fiat semper dominae yes always lord or the way i like to put
it is semper fiat always yes lord now luisa had been has been telling us in the last couple of
messages how extraordinary painful it was for her to not have jesus around so in the next section
here jesus is going to explain what he calls the passion of love in other words the entire
spiritual life is all about love the whole thing after this luisa said with my thought i placed myself
near jesus in the garden of get seminee and i prayed him to let me penetrate into that love now
look at the word penetrate if you prayer is very dangerous because god is listening
and if you say something that he really likes it was going to be consequences if you ask to
penetrate into his love then you're going to have to go down that painful route that he went down
because that's when he manifested his absolutely inexplicable love to us when i asked the lord
at the end of last year if i could somehow come to understand something of his reaction
to the scarching at the pillar or why got a little experience of it in january
so if you ask to penetrate something yeah he'll give it to you all right but you have to know
what you asked so luisa says i want to penetrate into that love but she's not afraid of suffering
in which god so loved me and my jesus moving again in the depth of my interior told me my daughter
enter into my love and never go out of it now we're used to him saying enter into my will
now it's enter into my love and never go out of it now the whole transformation that's required of us
is to turn from selfishness to love god is love and god made everything out of love as we've been
reading he created everything in the universe out of love he created us out of love he redeemed us
out of love he worked it out that we should be conceived in love that we should be nurtured
in the womb in love that we should grow up in a loving family and when we reach adulthood that
we're ready to pass the love on and in the meantime we're supposed to grow in love interiorly
and we cannot return back to him unless we have become love because love alone is the baggage
that gets into heaven all other baggage is prohibited so the big thing for us is the change
over from selfishness to love so jesus said go and enter into my love and never go out of it
and run after it he said do everything through love and or stop within love itself
so that you may understand well how much i have loved the creature so again that's jeremya 31-3
and it's sam 1 4 5 verses 13 and 17 and 1 john 4 7 they're all familiar texts for you now
everything in me is love around her god's nature is love his his essence is love
and so all his dealings with us are love now sometimes it takes a bit of work on our part
to think that something that is we've had to go through was actually love
but if you penetrate it with him and ask the holy spirit for insight you'll find that it actually
was love in creating this human creature the divinity intended to love her always
in everything both inside and outside of her god was to run towards her with a continuous
and incessant new act of love everything about god was to be new new new new and you'll hear
louisa saying for example that on the night when judas betrayed jesus that jesus showed him new
love love he hadn't shown him before therefore he said i can say that in each thought each gaze
each word each breath each heartbeat and in all the rest of the person
runs an act of eternal love now he said that a few pages back as well
but if the divinity intended to love this creature always and in everything
it was because god wanted to receive in everything the requital of the new and incessant love of the
creature now love is a circle we all know that unrequited love is the hardest thing to endure
if love goes out of me to another person then the cycle is not complete if love doesn't come back
in some way it's not complete and love is meant to be this cycle it goes out from god to us and it
should come back from us to god you who have brought children into the world know that you bring forth
this child in love and the only thing you want from the child is love coming back we're not asking
the child to pay for their food and accommodation you're not asking them to pay for their education
all you want is love coming back love is a is a circle and it must be complete so jesus is saying
here that god intended sending love to us in absolutely everything inside of us and outside of us
but he wanted a response of love from the creature the divine will wanted to give love in order to
receive love so let me show you the giving love is john 15 9 as the father has loved me so i have
loved you us giving love back to god is deuteronomy 6 4 to 10 you shall love the lord your god with
all your heart and all your soul and all your mind and all your being and love your neighbor
as yourself i want to give you deuteronomy 7 13 and i want to give you deuteronomy 10 verse 12
11 verse 1 and i have to say etc etc it's all over the bible okay so it is a circle and he wants
love in return but he said this didn't happen not only did the creature not want to keep the
rhythm of love what i call the circle of love and respond to the echo of the love of the creator
but she rejected this love not only did she reject it she denied it and not only did she denied
she offended it so this is the position of fallen man and so in the fall of the human race human
beings gave god an experience he never had before and that is sorrow and suffering
and this is a whole big topic i'm not going into right now so our journey back to god
is a journey of sorrow and suffering all of that everybody said you go out on this ray of love
you have to come back on this ray of love but if you put the sorrow and suffering into the mix
then sorrow and suffering is what accompanies you on the journey
at this affront jesus said the divinity didn't stop
but continued its new and incessant love towards the creature but since the creature wouldn't receive
it heaven and earth remained filled with it waiting for somebody to take this love in order to be
able to respond so in the next paragraph he talks about love can be repaid by love alone
and not only that but love lives by giving and so god keeps giving to us giving giving giving
giving and we have to learn how to respond and learn how to love in fact when god decides when
he proposes all adverse events do not change him in other words god's decisions are immutable
they're eternal and so the fall didn't change his eternal decision to love us otherwise we would
have been wiped out he remains immutable which is unchangeable and this is why moving on to another
excessive love i the word of god came upon the earth became incarnate and i took on a humanity
i gathered within myself all this love which filled heaven on earth in order to
requite the divinity with as much love for as much as it had given and was to give to creatures
so when jesus came on the earth he took all that love that was stored in heaven and on earth and
began to give god back the requital of love so this is the headline for us he's our model
and he said i constituted myself the love of each thought of each gaze of each word of each heartbeat
of each movement and of each step of the creature so jesus gave back the response of love for every
single thing in us he gave it to the father and he tells us the blessed mother gave it as well
he encourages louisa to give it and then he encourages us to do it we've got to put in something as well
therefore he said my humanity even in its littlest fiber was worked by the hands of the eternal
love now i think that eternal love should have capital e and a capital l because he's talking
about the divinity so i was worked by the hands of the eternal love for my celestial of my celestial
father in order to give me the capacity to be able to enclose all the love that the divinity
wanted to give to creatures now why did jesus have to be given the capacity and he's talking
about his humanity needed to be given the capacity to take all the love of all creatures from adam to
zakari because humanity is limited his divinity wasn't what his humanity was and so god gave him
the capacity because you we were just being told in the last messages that the more acts you do the
more your capacity is increased and so he said i gave to god the love of everyone and i constituted
myself the love of each act of the creature so jesus did what god intended and that is that love
would be the source of everything that love would be the origin of everything
and that love would be the motivation for everything and i mean everything thoughts words actions
motivation steps everything so each one of your thoughts he said is encircled by my incessant
acts of love there's nothing inside or outside of you which is not surrounded by my repeated
acts of love i have to move on because the time is over but would you ever take that off the book
write it down and say lord i want to take these acts and let you use them to embellish my soul
this is why in this garden he said that's garden of gethsemane he said my humanity moaned and
panted and agonized and it felt crushed under the weight of so much love because i love and i'm not
loved in return he said he was just the unrequited love and that is the great agony the pains of love
he said are the most bitter the most cruel they are pains without pity more painful than my very
passion he said not to be loved oh if they loved me the weight of so much love would become light
because when love is returned is loved in return it remains quenched and satisfied in the very love
of the beloved in the last year i think of his life st frances of his sissy was heard
and several of his ecstasies saying love is not loved love is not loved
and here jesus is saying his agony is that love is not loved okay and what we have to discover
is that we must love him we must do everything to show that love is coming back to him and we do
it in the name of everybody so that we put love on the hearts and in the minds of everybody
but when love is not loved in return he said it goes mad at raves and it feels the love which it
had issued being repaid by an act of death see then how much more bitter and painful was my passion
of love because you know louisa said he had three passions the passion of love the passion of sin
and the passion of the jews because if in my passion they gave me only one death that is the
passion of the jews and in the passion of love they made me suffer as many deaths for as many
acts of love as had come out of me for which i was not requited therefore you my daughter
come to requite me for so much love in my will you will find all this love as though in act
everything that god does is alive active present available now so we can go into any of the mysteries
of christ and we can actually enter them and you can actually be there in getsemane with jesus
you can be with him and the disciples at the last supper it is really incredible you can go back
into any part of his life it's really really fantastic so in my will he said you will find
all this love as though in act you can make it your own and together with me constitute yourself
the love of each act of the creature to give me the requital of the love of all
so we're going to leave it there for tonight and i want to finish with a tiny little prayer
and my prayer is this holy father let the chalice of my will pass from me
not my will but dine be done may your will be done in may in the church in the world for all time
for the complete triumph of the two hearts of jesus and mary amen